anti-establishment protesters are up
against a state that has become
increasingly militarized they tried but
failed to stop Lebanon's parliament from
convening to give a vote of confidence
in the new government security forces
who had already heavily fortified the
central Beirut district confronted the
demonstrators the parliamentary meeting
came as Lebanon faces its worst economic
and financial crisis in decades the Army
is blocking our way they are protecting
the criminals and thieves instead of
protecting the people they should put
those thieves in jail for stealing the
country's money instead of putting
people in jail officials defied popular
anger hundreds of military and security
personnel were deployed to ensure
politicians reach the Parliament
building some of their convoys were
harassed demonstrators have for months
been trying to topple a political class
they blame for corruption and
mismanagement they are against the new
cabinet since it was appointed by the
same party governed the government
receives the vote of confidence since
the ruling alliance controls parliament
it is now trying to convince the
Lebanese to give it a chance by
promising to fight corruption implement
reforms and prepare an emergency plan by
the end of the months every day that
passes without the implementation of the
government's plan the country and its
people will suffer more losses it could
be a complete collapse which would be
hard to get out of it it is our duty to
be honest with the Lebanese people but
some of the measures will be painful but
we will try not to affect low-income
earners many Lebanese believes a new
government's economic plan and policies
are no different from previous ones
the new government has consistently
shown its willingness to use force to
stay in power but it is not helping it
gain credibility many Lebanese say they
won't give up in their struggle against
the authorities and it's not just them
who don't have any faith in the new
cabinets reform plan tuesday's
confidence vote may not mean much if
lebanon doesn't get the billions of
dollars to get out of the crisis the
United Nations says there will be no
blank checks until there are serious
reforms zanaffar al Jazeera Beirut